are you looking for more from your
career do you wish you could be right
there at the cutting edge with just a
little more knowledge and access to some
of the leading minds in your field today
it could happen and it would open so
many doors for you increase your earning
potential compete for the best jobs be
prepared for new assignments or
challenges that demand more expertise to
prepare for coming changes or simply to
realize your full intellectual potential
in a new field you know you've got to
further your education to earn an
advanced certificate or degree discover
the Stanford center for professional
development at Stanford University
explore the exciting array of choices at
one of the world's top-ranked
universities where you can build a
better future for yourself as you
prepare to work on some of the Grand
Challenges of our time we connect
professionals worldwide to the research
and instructional resources of Stanford
University once qualified you can
participate in seminars take individual
graduate and professional courses pursue
graduate and professional certificates
even study for Master of Science degrees
on a part-time basis courses are
delivered online on the Stanford campus
and at your company worksite Stanford's
close ties with industry and its role in
the genesis of Silicon Valley continued
to stimulate this exciting Laboratory of
ideas for Sue your studies in the
birthplace of industries past present
and future learn from celebrated
Stanford faculty members like Dan Bonet
whose groundbreaking work on
identity-based encryption provides a key
management system used by over 2 million
people today solve problems by gaining
expert insight you'll explore
cutting-edge theory and how to execute
well with elegant solutions to complex
problems build a better tomorrow with
the knowledge you gain today your degree
or certificate from Stanford will also
help you build your career here's what
some of our students have to say about
us
I now pay closer attention to the
decisions which are made at the director
and above level and focus on how it
applies to the greater company's
strategy the professors here excited
about teaching their students where is
it other universities they can be more
involved in their research there's a
spirit of openness of innovation of
Stanford that's very inspirational
advance your knowledge and accelerate
your future with a Stanford center for
professional development contact us to
speak with a representative thank you